700 ch otages étrangers libéré par
bagdad dont deux français dix sept
femmes et cinq enfants sont arrivés à
paris rabier férès deux fuyards ne cache
pas l'échec sur le terrain diplomatique
les conséquences économiques en france
de l'accident le golf michel rocard
apporte son soutien à pierre bérégovoy
mais donne aussi quelques gages au ps
cyclisme le belge rudy dhaenens nouveau
champion du monde professionnel sur
route il devance son compatriote de bolt
et l'italien bougnot bonsoir une petite
phrase aujourd'hui de michel rocard
risque de bouleverser vos habitudes et
de provoquer une nouvelle grogne des
automobilistes le premier ministre pour
économiser l'énergie et les vies
humaines est favorable à l'abaissement
de la vitesse autorisée en ville et sur
les autoroutes
claudine la vitesse limitée à 70 km
heure sur les routes annoncé france soir
la semaine dernière ce sera peut être
bientôt réalité
l' agence française pour les économies
d'énergie a étudié l'impact d'une
réduction de la vitesse de 20 km/heure
sur la consommation en carburant avec
une limitation à 110 km/heure sur
autoroute 70 sur les routes et 50 en
ville on ferait l'économie de 2,3
millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole
soit 5 5% de la consommation automobile
si de plus les conducteurs conduisent
plus souplement règles mieux leurs
moteurs et évite de prendre leur voiture
pour faire un kilomètre l'économie
totale serait de 4,7 millions de tonnes
de pétrole soit 11 % d'économies selon
lagence à 25 dollars le baril la facture
énergétique se trouverait allégée de
quatre milliards et demi de francs et
les automobilistes économiserait en
moyenne 750 francs par an l'état en
revanche n'y trouverait pas son compte
à raison de 4 francs de taxes par litre
de super ce sont plusieurs milliards de
francs qui monteront dans les caisses à
noter cependant que michel rocard a
évoqué la réduction de la vitesse sur
autoroute et en ville mais pas sur les
routes et on parle de 110 km/h sur les
autoroutes
l'émotion la joie ce matin à orly mais
aussi l'angoissé la peur pour ceux qui
sont restés à bagdad 22 otages français
17 femmes cinq enfants sont arrivés à
paris à orly pour la 3 laurent grenier
après six heures de vol les 22 français
libérés arrivent enfin à paris leurs
familles attendent depuis de longues
heures l'atterrissage du boeing irakien
dans le hall une femme hôtesse de l'air
air france retrouve son enfant et son
mari après un mois de peur et d'angoissé
il est difficile de contenir son émotion
les enfants débarquent avec leur maman
les sentiments sont mitigés les rires
alternent avec les larmes
la plupart des femmes sont inquiètes
leur mare ils sont encore retenus en
irak et au co et jean-marie la barre
votre mari resté là bas on a pas été
maltraités tout va bien et a encore
beaucoup de garçons là bas on ne veut
rien dire pour ça c'est tout
on a peur pour eux qu'on a peur on vous
qui leur arrive rien qui rentre comme
nous c'est toi ils sont sur des cibles
stratégiques sur des sites mais tout va
bien vous inquiétez pas tous vont
l'arrêter vous même je peux pas en dire
plus il vous plait elisabeth le naf
originaire d'amiens est rentrée mais son
ami jean michel est encore otage du
régime de saddam hussein sur l'entier de
notre fils ni via avec elle et pour à
nouveau les et renseignements savoir
vous étaient pendants
et comment
notre très soulagé oui mais pas
complètement aux gens que mon fils est
là bas puis enfin tous ceux qui restent
monique couteau a retrouvé sa belle
fille et ses deux petits enfants fagnes
et marion tous les otages libérés sont
déterminés ils veulent maintenant se
battre pour obtenir très vite le retour
de ceux qui l'ont laissé sur place
au total plus de 700 ressortissants
étrangers ont quitté bagdad depuis la
nuit dernière après 232 britannique
arrivé à londres un groupe de quelques
25 femmes et enfants en compagnie du
pasteur noir américain jesse jackson
sont arrivés à washington
les otages libérés ont été accueillis
dans les salons de l'aéroport par leurs
familles des fonctionnaires du
département d'état se faire également
l'aéroport ainsi que l'ambassadeur
d'irak à washington ces premières
libérations ne doivent pas faire oublier
les milliers d'occidentaux toujours
détenus en irak et au koweït des otages
de toutes nationalités et destinée
aujourd'hui encore à servir de boucliers
humains
mathilde pradier la liberté pour 700
otages et on ne peut que se réjouir
je suis heureux que les américains
puissent sortir de là mais il ya un côté
tapageur et une certaine brutalité dans
cette décision irakienne
c'est ce qu'a déclaré george bush hier
dans sa résidence d'été pour le chef
d'état américain cette libération compte
gouttes et îles basses révoltante et
doivent faire le malaise du monde arabe
en irak plus de 1500 femmes et enfants
autorisé à partir attend toujours de
quitter le pays
leurs visas de sortie en poche parmi eux
173 français la libération des uns ne
doit pas faire oublier que plusieurs
milliers d'autres occidentaux servent
encore de boucliers humains sur des
sites stratégiques selon le quai d'orsay
environ soixante français se
trouveraient dans ce cas avec parmi eux
des femmes et des enfants
poussant le cynisme jusqu'au bout saddam
hussein continue d'ordonner le départ de
certains américains et le transfert de
certains autres en fin de semaine
dernière cinq nouveaux américains ont
été emmenés de leur hôtel de koweït vers
une destination inconnue
mais margaret thatcher refuse de céder
au chantage
ce n'est pas la question des otages qui
empêchera d'agir militairement contre
l'irak
le premier ministre britannique a
déclaré devoir prendre toutes les
mesures vitales pour arrêter un
dictateur reste l'échec de la diplomatie
javier perez de
hier est arrivé ce soir à paris où il a
été reçu pendant 45 minutes par roland
dumas le ministre français des affaires
étrangères le secrétaire général des
nations unies n'a pas caché sa déception
l'entretien vient juste de se terminer
écoutez tout d'abord roland dumas parce
que ce travail devrait tv sans qui
permet d'avoir une bonne radiographie
jeu coupelle de la situation à une idée
exacte de ce que les irakiens veulent ou
ne veulent pas s'étendre bien ou que ce
voyage n'était pas inutile en effet et
gilles n'a pas été très productif non
plus avec l'irak veut c'est de
restez vous et c'est qui est
inacceptable que la communauté
internationale pour des cons sensibilité
et pour le secrétaire général et du
point de vue humanitaire
les irakiens considèrent que c'est
qu'ils ont fait est assez rare je trouve
que ce n'est pas se disant qu'ils faut
que tous les étrangers quittent le
territoire territoire irakien et tout
être bien s'ils le désirent
alors donc ne sera de ses poids de ces
deux points de vue
je suis profondément
les sikhs et je vais due uniquement
quand vous savez même pas ce que je
m'attendais à une certaine flexibilité
qui pourrait être éventuellement le
début d'une solution pacifique et juste
du problème mais malheureusement je n'ai
rien obtenu
alors envoyé spécial de la trois a man
jean-claude perpère vous rentrer ce soir
de jordanie l'échec des négociations
c'était prévisible mais bien sûr c'est
prévisible puisque on savait que le
secrétaire général des nations-unies ne
pourrait pas transiger sur les décisions
du conseil de sécurité et on savait que
je savais que tarek aziz le ministre et
le ministre irakien des affaires
étrangères
lui ne pourrait faire aucune concession
sur les ordres qu'il avait reçu de
saddam hussein et du conseil de
commandement de la révolution irakienne
alors eu un petit espoir légumes petit
espoir abandonné parce que le fait même
que le secrétaire général des
nations-unies perez et coillard habile
négociateur s'impliquent lui même
personnellement à fenêtre certain espoir
bien évidemment mais on le savait déjà
que ce serait très difficile et que la
partie des pratiquement perdue d'avancé
comment expliquez-vous jean-claude le
fait que saddam hussein reste inflexible
sur l'annexion du koweit et libère en
même temps 700 otages femmes et enfants
mais c'est d'abord sur les fluctuations
delà de la politique de la politique de
saddam hussein vous savez bon ils sont
faits la fois le tour à tour le chaud et
le froid alors on peut tout de même
constater d'une part qui lui reste dix
mille otages ça c'est une affaire
entendue et puis ensuite si la libéra
c'est libérer 700 otage sur sur 10000 ne
va pas atténuer forcément ça son image
de boucher de bagdad et des dictateurs
inhumain alors peut-être que il a voulu
faire reculer la reprise de la tension
qui ne saurait manquer de de reprendre
après après l'échec des négociations les
chevilles sur les peyriacois ya eu aussi
aussi c'est un manipulateur des opinions
publiques donc ce qui ce qui l'a peut
être cherché à faire c'est ménager le
suspense et faire accroire aux
gouvernements occidentaux aux opinions
publiques occidentales que le sort des
dix mille autres otages lui étaient
négociables salue lui permet de gagner
du temps et on sait que chaque jour qui
passe lui permet d'accroître son emprise
sur le koweït marqué 20 buts et ça aussi
merci jean claude perpère saddam hussein
qui vient de décider l'expulsion des
deux cents journalistes étrangers un qui
était pour l'instant à bagdad
les conséquences économiques de la crise
dans le golfe ont agité ce week-end
l'université d'été du parti socialiste
qui se tient dans le var ce matin michel
record s'est livré à un véritable
exercice d'équilibré soutenir pierre
bérégovoy tout en rassurant le parti
socialiste à la garde freinet dans le
var daniel sportiello arrêtons les
querelles a demandé michel rocard face à
la cohésion nationale exprimée par la
quasi totalité des partis politiques
il est demandé aux socialistes de ne pas
être en reste face aux mauvais procès sa
réponse est nette
une rigueur ni austérité ne sont à
l'ordre du jour mais seulement la
prudence
c'est pourquoi il soutient four ministre
de l'économie si nous ne faisions pas à
temps ce qu'il faut faire
deux modèles nous risquerions plus tard
d'avoir à faire beaucoup plus douloureux
et je tiens à préciser mais vous en
doutiez je pense que je suis là dessus
en accord absolument complet avec pierre
bergot la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés michel rocard et pour également
car cette mesure aura des répercussions
sur l'emploi
ranger donc au vieux clichés doctrinaire
sur les cadeaux aux entreprises
lance-t-il à l'adresse des socialistes
les plus réticents et pour bien montrer
que les salariés seront pas oubliés ils
rappellent qu'un troisième plan pour
l'emploi est en préparation à matignon
l'effort sera demandé à tous chacun
devra y contribuer et contribue à
proportion de ses capacités
la justice dans la répartition de
l'effort sera notre principe directeur
en approuvant pierre bérégovoy en tenant
le discours de l'effort
le premier ministre n'aura donné aucun
gage à ses alliés d'hier mauroy et
jospin mais michel rocard se met à
croire que les circonstances actuelles
un pool devons ce qu'il appelle la
cohésion nécessaire
de son côté raymond voir invités du
forum rmc libération a estimé que le
gouvernement ne pourrait pas échapper à
des mesures d'austérité
quand je faisais face à des chocs
pétroliers et que j'avais dit il faut
une boutique d'austérité les socialistes
ont dit l'austérité jamais ils ont été
contraints ensuite de faire une
politique était très voisines de ce que
je faisais mais comme il faut marquer sa
différence
ils ont parlé de rigueur je constate
qu'aujourd'hui il me rallie austérité et
rigueur
j'attends qu'ils trouvent le troisième
mot
et est-ce qu'une gare la réalité ils n'y
seront donc ils vont trouver un
troisième mot et tout le monde sera
content arlette chabot difficile malgré
tout d'échapper au mot rigueur oui si
vous voulez avant l'été tout allait bien
on parlait de la prospérité française on
évoquer le partage des fruits de la
croissance se retrouver la lutte contre
les inégalités avec un gouvernement et
un parti socialiste ont plus aiguillonné
par françois mitterrand qui dénonçait
ceux qui s'enrichissent en dormant
aujourd'hui bien le paysage évidemment à
changer d'abord parce qu'on s'est aperçu
que la croissance espérée ne serait pas
aussi forte que prévu et ensuite
maintenant parce qu'il faut évidemment
avaler la facture pétrolière due à la
crise du golfe alors pour le
gouvernement aujourd'hui il ya
évidemment deux priorités la lutte
contre l'inflation et le chômage pour
assurer le parti socialiste michel
rocard dit bien qu'il n'est pas question
de renoncer à la nouvelle étape sociale
qui n'est pas question de laisser le
patronat abandonné en route les
négociations sur les bas et les moyens
salaires
néanmoins on comprend bien que si on
lâche un petit peu de ce côté on lâchera
sans doute beaucoup moins que prévu
l'état donnons l'exemple avec les
fonctionnaires et l'autre par le
gouvernement fera tout pour aider les
entreprises à investir donc michel
rocard aujourd'hui a voulu commencer à
préserver la cohésion sociale en
annonçant un effort partagé et une
rigueur limité mais une rigueur tout de
même merci arlette chabot dans le var
toujours mais sur l'île de bendor c'est
françois léotard qui s'est exprimé
devant l'université d'été du parti
républicain la situation dans le golfe a
bien sûr été au coeur de son
intervention sur place michel lemaire
l'université d'été c'était la fois une
tribune médiatique est un lieu de
travail
bandol s'est ouverte sur la première
vocation elle s'est refermée sur la
seconde
la proposition de gérard longuet
largement commentée de faire adhérer
directement le parti républicain lui pf
avec
frémir dans le camp giscardien françois
léotard s'est bien gardé de reprendre la
proposition il est vrai qu'à moins de
deux mois du renouvellement des
instances du p r
personne n'a vraiment intérêt à
provoquer la division du parti restait
donc avant tout à regonfler les
militants pour les échéances de la
rentrée sur certains points on sentait
néanmoins de fortes nuances entre les
ténors du ps sur la crise du golfe
paraît alors fais pas une affaire
personnelle contre monsieur chevènement
je crois que monsieur ch'ti en a quitté
le gouvernement pour des faits qu'il
était certes beaucoup plus ridicule mais
beaucoup moins grave
je crois que monsieur le ministre de la
défense aurait dû démissionner de façon
à redonner de la crédibilité à la
politique extérieure française françois
lyotard apparaissait lui est nettement
plus consensuel nous avons près de dix
mille français aujourd'hui les
inviterait de 10000 qui sont soit
soldats soit otage et je voudrais qu
aucun des propos des hommes politiques
français ne puisse être de nature à
faire douter les uns ou à faire pleurer
les autres j'aimerais que le soyons dans
une attitude de grande responsabilité
vis-à-vis de ces qui se passe autour de
mon pays autour de notre pays
fin d'université donc en demi teinte le
p r a déjà entamé son compte à rebours
pour son conseil national de fin
novembre à l'étranger toujours le sort
des indiens marque toujours menacés au
canada l'un de leurs représentants est
intervenu à genève pour demander une
intervention de l'onu afin d'éviter je
cite un bain de sang avec l'armée
canadienne béatrice nivois l'armée
canadienne a gagné deux fois entre hier
et aujourd'hui la guerre des nerfs qui
l'opposé aux mohawks
elle contrôle aujourd'hui l'autoroute
que bloqué depuis 54 jours les mohawks
des indiens canadiens qui voulait
préserver leurs terres sacrées de
l'agrandissement d'un golf
elle a pénétré hier dans leurs réserves
avec ses blindés
prétextant des coups de feu échangés
entre indiens la confusion la plus
totale régnait dans cette réserve ou
civil et guerrier indien était en
désaccord sur la manière d'affronter
l'armée les mohawks ont-ils pour autant
enterrer la hache de guerre
une cinquantaine d'entre eux armés
jusqu'aux dents se sont réfugiés dans la
forêt et surtout un de leurs
représentants à l'onu a demandé
officiellement que des observateurs
viennent
glay le conflit sur le terrain voilà
attentat au pays basque espagnol un
policier et un civil ont été tués ce
matin dans un attentat à la voiture
piégée contre un poste de la garde
civile dans le port de bilbao de
contractuels municipaux chargés de la
surveillance du stationnement ont
également été blessées dans l'explosion
l'attentât a été commis à l'aide d'une
voiture piégée avec 40 à 50 kg d'un
explosif et voitures lancées en marche
arrière contre le poste de la garde
civile
en france les opposants au tgv
méditerranée ne désarme pas après avoir
encore bloqués des trains l'année
dernière près d'avignon
ils ont fait preuve aujourd'hui
d'originalité dans la drôme reportage
d'isabelle dupont refusons de payer nos
impôts locaux à l'état puisque l'état
veut nous nuire tous les moyens sont
bons pour dire non au tgv empaqueter
comme une lettre pour le président cette
maison est un symbole de protestation
l'autoroute passe à 200 mètres à peine
et le tracé ouest du tgv passera de
l'autre côté à 250 m prise en sandwich
entre le train et les voitures les
habitants ne toucheront pas d'indemnités
il faudra supporter je crois que suis
obligée de rester là je n'avais pas trop
de choix ue
pourquoi parce que la maison sera bandas
ou alors dans des conditions telles que
financièrement ce serait une catastrophe
dans le club n'aura pas le choix
restez subir subir le passage de 160 tgv
par jour
pourtant à alan on se défend d'être sur
le fait d anti tgv ce que l'on dénonce
c'est l'idée qu'il faille imposer aux
riverains un cumul des nuisances
on évoque aussi des privilèges
politiques qui aurait permis à certains
d'être épargnée par le tgv au détriment
des autres et jean qui décide de
privilégier leurs intérêts sont les
politiques qui aujourd'hui disent pour
protéger mes vignes pour protéger la
forêt pour protéger mes terres où ma
circonscription
passons dans les zones les plus
urbanisées de la drôme cette vente relie
prochain max querrien le président de la
commission d'examen du tracé tgv sera à
alan pendant une heure il rencontrera
les différentes associations
une mission de concertation à laquelle
les habitants ne croit plus beaucoup le
premier bilan d'une saison estivale
malheureusement pratiquement terminé
premier constat le tourisme au vert est
en pleine croissance plus de 25 % des
vacanciers ont séjourné cette année dans
des gîtes ruraux et pour certains
agriculteurs cela a constitué aussi un
moyen providentiel dirais-je pour éviter
un éventuel dépôt de bilan les vacances
à la ferme c'est un peu le retour aux
sources dans le périgord reportage de
marie-odile pas niaise et de christian
de carrière legrand coderre hameau perdu
au coeur du périgord 40 habitants en
hiver le double en était ici avant
l'apparition du tourisme vers les
maisons aujourd'hui restauré en gîtes
ruraux tomber en ruine et les petites
exploitations agricoles périclitait
comme celle de bernard gaillard poret
tabac ne suffisait plus à faire vivre sa
famille
sa seule richesse sa ferme en pleine
région touristique alors l'ancienne
étable est devenu chambres d'hôtes et la
salle à manger accueille désormais qui
veut partager le repas familial c'était
ça ou la catastrophe soit continuer à
faire ce que moi j'avais commencé à
faire et ma femme allait travailler
ailleurs
ou alors déposé aujourd'hui bernard
gaillard avoue bien vivre il réalise
près de la moitié de son chiffre
d'affaires grâce au tourisme une chance
dans cette région traditionnellement
tournée vers l'élevage et qui supporte
mal sécheresse et baisse des cours de la
viande
je pense que dans la mesure où les
visiteurs vivent déjà des difficultés et
que à l'avenir les difficultés vont et
croissante dans la mesure où on sait
bien que les prix vont continuer
vraisemblablement abaissée et que la
concurrence sera de plus en plus dur par
rapport à aux productions courante
c'est certain que c'est aujourd'hui que
l'agriculteur doit s'intéresser au
tourisme ceto d'aujourd'hui qui doit
penser à sa reconversion
pas de solution miracle on ne
s'improvise pas aubergiste région
attrayante mise de fonds au départ mais
surtout sens du contact et talents
culinaires s'impose car si les
vacanciers sont de plus en plus nombreux
à redécouvrir la campagne ils sont aussi
souvent plus exigeants que sur les côtes
on n'est pas du tout la faux je n'aime
pas les grands hôtels j'aime pas le seul
habit de la crise
je recherche le calme le probable plutôt
avec les gens du cru
puis la bonne entente que nous avons
trouvé ce soir resté stable d'autres
c'était vraiment très très agréable le
tourisme rural une alternative pour
casser l'engrenage de la surproduction
et de l'endettement des agriculteurs
pourtant ils ne sont que 2 % qui comme
bernard et sa famille ont choisi cette
voie pour vivre au pays et le faire
vivre les sports cyclisme le belge rudy
dhaenens nouveau champion du monde
professionnel sur route ce matin au
japon au terme d'une course passionnante
il a devancé son compatriote de wolf
mais aussi d'une you et lemon
commentaire jean philippe guillin
fantastic finale à utsunomiya à moins de
cinq kilomètres de l'arrivée le français
martial gayant est dans le groupe de
tête
juste derrière danone et de wolf les
deux belges mais dans la dernière
ascension du mont coq achi le peloton
qui a compté plus de six minutes de
retard revient très fort en menée par
les italiens gaillon et rejoint par
lemon douniaux delgado est presque tous
les favoris mais devant audi des landes
et dirk de wolf résiste pour défendre
les 30 secondes qui les sépare alors que
leurs poursuivants après 261 km et
malgré la très forte chaleur
le duo belge va signer un magnifique
doublé premier est champion du monde
roddy danneels qui remporte ainsi son
premier grand titre deuxième de wolf
troisième ligne au quatrième lemon
jalabert promis
pensée est sixième au design ce qui
succède au palmarès à greg lemon ne
faisait pas partie des favoris deuxième
cette saison du tour des flandres il est
surtout spécialiste des classiques le
maillot de champion du monde revient
donc aujourd'hui à un belge après un
internet de 6 ans et la victoire
en 84 de claude rich et lyon le bilan
rose de l'équipe de france d'athlétisme
aux championnats d'europe à split 10
médailles dont trois en or et puis hier
soir vous en souvenez un fabuleux record
du monde en 4 x 100 m caroline since
premier grand bonheur celui du
décathlonien à christian plaziat
première médaille d'or française avec
8500 74 points il pulvérise son record
de france et prouve qu'il n'est pas
l'homme des rendez vous manqués celle
que les athlètes surnomme au survol de
100 m haies 12 secondes 79 100e pleure
de joie pour la seule médaille d'or
féminine
quatre hommes pour un record du monde
historique morinière sangouma trois
balles
marie-rose détrônent les américains
trente et une secondes 79
le relais français entrent dans la
légende les sprinteurs sont les grands
gagnants de ces championnats
trois français en finale du 100 m et
l'argent pour daniel sangouma à quelques
centièmes seulement du britannique
lindford christie l'argent encore pour
jean-charles trouabal sur 200 m et en
anglais est encore devant mais il ya
aussi les oublier ceux dont les
médailles sont passés inaperçus et qui
pourtant préfigure le renouveau de la
course de fond française marathonien
c'est être solitaire dans la souffrance
mais aussi le bonheur dominique
chauvelier est le premier français
depuis mimoun a décroché une médaille en
marathon le bronze également pour la
marathonienne maria rebelo le lui
d'origine portugaise qui murmurent
l'hymne de son pays natal jouer en
l'honneur de la médaille d'or le bronze
aussi pour thierry toutain troisième du
20 km marche
sous une pluie diluvienne bronze pour
annette sergent seule française à
défendre le demi fond en l'occurrence le
10000 m bronze enfin pour marie josé
pérec sur 400 m prochain objectif les
jeux olympiques de barcelone
la mode masculine pour terminer ce
journal ouverture à paris du salon de
l'élégance salon de l'habillement
réservé aux messieurs
le tout sous l'oeil très avertis des
manuels france
cette année on annonce précieux et en
couleur l'homme nouveau cru 91 vient
d'arriver lui passe muraille en flanelle
grise ni post-adolescent bigarrée il
peut enfin choisir son style suivant
l'humeur du jour lui ressorti de
berceaux pour les silhouettes je vais ni
de newman allure nouveaux pères
décontracté style blanc bleu
geste 10 goals haut en couleur chez
aurélie testud aventuriers de la city
adolfo dominguez et golden boy
authentique chez paco rabanne
tout est une question d'imagination
l'époque vu que l'on soigne son look de
sous les eaux ci dessus en choisissant
le clin d'oeil de l'accessoire
voilà petit ensemble qui ravira michel
tour et le tiercé quarté qui s'est
courue aujourd'hui à longchamp pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 2 le 10 et le
4 pour gagner dans l'ordre donc 600
francs et dans un ordre différent 120
francs 40
enfin le quarté + pour 8 francs vous
rajoutez le 8 et vous gagnez dans
l'ordre 4772 francs 80 et dans le
désordre 406 francs 40 dans un instant
la météo plein soleil je vous le disais
de michel tour et je vous retrouve à 22h
pour soir trois très bons de victoire